>>> AND I QUOTE, GO F YOURSELF.
SUCH A LOVELY SENTIMENT THAT
SENATOR RAND PAUL'S STRATEGIST
TWEETED ABOUT DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
IN RESPONSE TO FAUCI GIVING HIS
OPINION THIS WEEK ON THE FUTURE
OF MASKS.
THAT THEY MIGHT BE A, QUOTE,
SEASONAL THING.
CLASSY RETORT.
SENATOR PAUL IS ALSO TROLLING
FAUCI AHEAD OF ANOTHER
APPEARANCE THIS MORNING ON THE
PANDEMIC WHICH HAS NOW CLAIMED
MORE THAN 600,000 AMERICAN
LIVES.
IN RESPONSE TO FAUCI SAYING HE'S
BEING POLITICIZED BY EXTREME
PEOPLE WHICH IS JUST A FACT,
PAUL REPLIED, LOOKING FORWARD TO
TOMORROW'S HEARING, DR. FAUCI,
PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE EXCLAMATION
POINT THERE AT THE END.
TO BE CLEAR, FAUCI IS NOT IMMUNE
FROM QUESTIONS OR SCRUTINY BUT
SENATOR PAUL WHO IS AN EYE
DOCTOR, APPROACHES THESE
HEARINGS AS IF THEY ARE A WWE
MATCH, INSTEAD OF TITILLATING A
WITTY CROWD HE BLOWS
DISINFORMATION ALL OVER THEM P.
AS MUCH AS I DISRESPECT YOU, DR.
FAUCI, I DON'T THINK YOU ARE THE
ONE PERSON WHO GETS TO MAKE A
DECISION.
>> I'VE NEVER MADE MYSELF OUT TO
BE THE END ALL.
>> DEVELOPED ENOUGH COMMUNITY
IMMUNITY THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER
HAVING THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ENOUGH IMMUNITY IN NEW YORK
CITY TO STOP --
>> I CHALLENGE THAT, SENATOR.
>> I'M AFRAID --
>> PLEASE, SIR, I WOULD LIKE TO
DO THIS BECAUSE THIS HAPPENS
WITH SENATOR RAND ALL THE TIME.
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING TO WHAT THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CDC SAID.
IN NEW YORK, IT'S ABOUT 22%.
IF YOU BELIEVE 22% IS HERD
IMMUNITY, I BELIEVE YOU ARE
ALONE IN THAT.
>> IF WE'RE NOT SPREADING THE
INFECTION, ISN'T IT JUST
THEATER?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> YOU HAVE THE VACCINE AND
YOU'RE WEARING TWO MASKS.
ISN'T THAT THEATER?
>> NO, HERE WE GO AGAIN WITH THE
THEATER.
>> NOTHING BRINGS OUT SENATOR
PAUL'S PROPENSITY TO ACT LIKE AN
ASS LIKE A CONGRESSIONAL
APPEARANCE BY FAUCI AND THAT'S
SAYING SOMETHING.
NOT SURPRISING, PAUL WAS ONE OF
THE ONLY LAWMAKERS WHO REFUSED
TO WEAR A MASK ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE WINTER.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK SENATOR
PAUL IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY TO
START WEARING A MASK ON THE
SENATE FLOOR LIKE THE ENTIRE
STAFF DOES ALL THE TIME.
>> I WISH SENATOR PAUL WOULD
SHOW THE RESPECT TO HIS
COLLEAGUES TO WEAR A MASK WHEN
HE'S ON THE SENATE FLOOR WALKING
AROUND AND SPEAKING.
>> SENATOR PAUL ALSO ADVISED
AMERICANS IN NOVEMBER TO TOSS
THE MASK, AGAIN, AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC.
>> IF YOU HAD THE DISEASE OR
YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED AND
YOU'RE SEVERAL WEEKS OUT FROM
YOUR SECOND DOSE, THROW YOUR
MASK AWAY AND TELL DR. FAUCI TO
TAKE A LEAP.
>> SENATOR PAUL'S FEUD WITH
FAUCI, HE OFTEN LIKES TO
PROJECT.
>> YOU COULD LOOK AT DR. FAUCI
AND SAY, WELL, WHAT IF THE
SPANISH FLU COMES BACK?
SHOULDN'T WE WEAR A MASK EVERY
YEAR FOR THE REST OF OUR LIFE
BECAUSE SOME DAY THE SPANISH FLU
IS GOING TO COME BACK?
SEE, THAT'S NOT SCIENCE.
THAT'S SORT OF EMOTIONALISM AND
FEARMONGERING.
>> FEARMONGERING.
AT LEAST SENATOR PAUL IS
STICKING TO HIS AREA OF
EXPERTISE HERE.
>> ARE THEY GOING TO HOLD ME
DOWN AND STICK A NEEDLE IN MY
ARM?
THEY PROBABLY WILL BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE BELIEVE IN THE IDEA THAT
THEY ARE SO RIGHT AND THAT THEIR
CAUSE IS SO RIGHTEOUS THAT THEY
CAN INFLICT IT ON OTHERS.
>> BUT THE FRAUD HAPPENED, THE
ELECTION IN MANY WAYS WAS
STOLEN.
>> I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
TELLING PRIVATE BUSINESS OWNERS.
I ABHOR RACISM.
I THINK IT'S A BAD BUSINESS
DECISION TO EVER EXCLUDE ANYBODY
FROM YOUR RESTAURANT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I DO
BELIEVE IN PRIVATE OWNERSHIP.
>> BUT I GUARANTEE THAT'S ONE OF
THEIR LONG-TERM GOALS TO HAVE
ONE SORT OF BORDERLESS MASK
CONTINENT.
>> I THINK THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WENT ON AT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION THAT ARE GOING TO
SHOCK PEOPLE.
>> ANYBODY HEARD ABOUT EBOLA?
IT IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IS THIS GOING TO BE A TERRIBLE
THING THAT RUNS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES?
I THINK NOBODY KNOWS BUT IS IT A
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION AND THE
PRESIDENT OUGHT TO BE A LITTLE
MORE FOCUSED ON?
>> THE CLINTON FOUNDATION WAS
CLEARED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, NO LESS, AND ON
THAT LAST ONE, HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT EBOLA.
HE WAS REALLY WORRIED ABOUT IT
UNDER A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
NINE PEOPLE INFECTED WITH EBOLA
RETURNED TO THE U.S.
TWO NURSES WERE INFECTED AND ONE
OF THOSE TRAVELERS DIED.
BUT A PANDEMIC THAT HAS CLAIMED
MORE THAN 500,000 AMERICAN
LIVES, PAUL ISN'T NEARLY AS
CONCERNED.
HE JETTISONED HIS OWN BELIEFS
ABOUT PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
WHEN HE WAS EXPOSED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS EARLY ON.
KNOWING HE WAS EXPOSED TO THE
VIRUS, HE STILL DECIDED TO HIT
UP THE SENATE GYM AND DO LAPS IN
THE POOL WHILE HE WAITED FOR HIS
TEST RESULTS.
THAT VISIT TO THE GYM EXPOSED
HIS COLLEAGUES, MANY OF WHOM ARE
IN THE HIGH-RISK CATEGORY
BECAUSE HE ENDED UP TESTING
POSITIVE, BECOMING THE FIRST
SENATOR THAT WE'RE AWARE OF TO
BE INFECTED.
AND FOR A GUY WHO HAS CHAMPIONED
HERD IMMUNITY, HE SURE HAS A
HISTORY OF CASTING DOUBT ON THE
VACCINES THAT COULD SAFELY GET
US THERE.
HE SAYS HE'S A PROPONENT OF
THEM, BUT --
>> YET, IT IS WRONG TO SAY THERE
ARE NO RISKS TO VACCINES.
EVEN THE GOVERNMENT ADMITS THAT
CHILDREN ARE SOMETIMES INJURED
BY VACCINES.
I'VE HEARD OF MANY TRAGIC CASES
OF WALKING, TALKING, NORMAL
CHILDREN WHO WOUND UP WITH
PROFOUND MENTAL DISORDERS AFTER
VACCINES.
>> IN DECEMBER, DESPITE HAVING
THE PRIVILEGE AND OPPORTUNITY TO
BE AMONG THE FIRST AMERICANS
VACCINATED, PAUL SAID, QUOTE, I
HAVE NOT CHOSEN TO BE VACCINATED
BECAUSE I GOT IT NATURALLY.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THAT NO
MORE THAN A HANDFUL OF REPORTS
OF PEOPLE GETTING IT AGAIN SO
THERE'S EVERY INDICATION THAT
HAVING BEEN INFECTED WITH IT
PROVIDES STRONG NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
WELL, LIKE ELVIS' KENTUCKY RAIN,
RAND PAUL'S COVID BS KEE